hello good people of the Internet I'm
Dave Rubin this is the Rubin report and
you're most likely watching on the
internet so we have to move fast because
you got porn open and okay here we go
so Egypt what was once one of the great
countries of the world
things have been not going as well as
they did say 2000 years ago or so their
top satirist the guy who's known as the
Egyptian Jon Stewart I want to get his
name right Bassam Yosef he was arrested
for guess what
providing satire he's since been
released for about 2,500 bucks and
before we get that far into it let's
let's take a look a little bit of that
satire Mohammed Morsi the Isthmus Nana
is still cool an attender Hanafi other
article and a shahira I mean
he truly is I mean he's doing a Jon
Stewart if Jon Stewart was not Jewish
that would be his gig all right so I
want to talk about what is going on in
Egypt and you know we had the whole
Egyptian revolution and everything but
things seem to be worse than when they
started
bill I'm gonna start with you what is
the deal in Egypt I don't know but I
think that bringing that kind of you
know dictatorial scrutiny to to humor
with make it a lot more interesting to
watch because anything that you say
you're willing to risk your you know
your freedom for and your and your life
for you know it better be funny I think
the fact that we have so much freedom in
this country and that you know the are
our Constitution guarantees us the right
to say anything it's it's too much of a
free fall and there's a lot of times
when I'm watching certain sketches on TV
certain comedians a lot of SNL stuff and
you're like man these people need to be
called on a part of it they needed
requests at least question and release
so that they get their their game
together they they should have to answer
for some of their their treasonous
attempts at humor yeah Sam what do you
think you're a satirist a comedy person
when you're doing pop trigger do you
feel that the government's gonna come
get you we don't and I tell you what we
wouldn't say half of the things 99
percent of the things on pop trigger if
we believed that especially some of my
co-hosts that we get on the show we have
a lot of comedians that come in the
showbread Ehrlich's on the show and we
speak exactly what we feel and you look
at some of the you know the comedians
today I mean they can actually you know
they can celebrate the President or our
government or they can hate on it and we
see that with you know a lot of the
people in Fox News we see that with Rush
Limbaugh can you imagine if the same
rules applied here we'd have a lot of
people locked up yeah yeah it seems to
me that comedy actually is sort of the
first thing that should come around in a
democracy they need this in Egypt
tremendously where do you think this
will fall out I mean do you think that
he will go back and do it again where
has he now been scared enough to just
forget offensive as this is to Egypt
Egypt's long line of satirist and the
distinguished lineage there
I'm not um how far back is that about
three years if or six months yeah you
know give or take your how you're
measuring it I'm not really very
concerned I think that you know that the
trajectory that we see Egypt long you
know playing along is going to really
lead to you know more open dialog and
you know Americans when we look back at
our own history and our own and a fight
for freedom and and how we and you know
how we went from you know authoritarian
rule to you know doing things on our own
yeah it's kind of we kind of wash over
some of the some of the you know that
the problems in the dirt that comes
along with going from authoritarianism
to a democracy and there's just some of
the growing pains that any situation you
know any situation like this will you
know will encounter and I think you're
gonna find the Egyptian Stephen Colbert
and the Egyptian Millbrook soon enough
and they can all be in jail together
apparently perhaps well I'm glad you
brought up the growing pains actually
because what do you guys think I mean it
seemed like they had a dictator and not
seemed like it was they had a dictator
in Egypt for about thirty years then
they had this Arab Spring thing and now
they have the Muslim Brotherhood who
really is more extreme than Mubarak was
in the first place so how long does it
take to get freedom well I mean like you
said I think I think you brought up a
really interesting point that you know
this doesn't happen overnight
unfortunately and I think that you know
the people of Egypt just have to
continue to fight they need to continue
to fight for the freedom they need to
continue to fight for their freedom of
speech and I thought you know it was
really great that Youssef how do you say
he's awesome he after he was released
from jail he actually went on to
continue to express what he really
believed and I have his quote here and I
thought it was very poignant he said if
there is anyone who has insulted
religion it is those who use Islam as a
weapon for political reasons so he's
going to continue to be him and I think
that's great he's going in the in the
right step in the right direction in the
right step so bill as a comedian is
there anything that you won't touch upon
that you think is actually too sacred to
really hit on well I think funny is the
that that's that's the bottom line but
also within that you know I guess have
certain personal standards that I
I don't I don't need to go beyond but
the bottom line is it is it funny and
and all you know what's a bill Santiago
personal standard line is it is it you
know the c-word is it the n-word
it spits look if it's in context it's
not a certain word but it also depends
how you arrive at it you know I mean
it's clever enough it almost justifies
anything you know it depends who you're
going after are you going after the are
you going after the victim are you going
after the power structure are you
reinforcing stereotypes are you shedding
any new light or really you're really
getting it off your chest you know are
you going for the lowest common
denominator making everybody feel good
about you know the stereotypes that they
feel like prolonging for a forever so
you know I have my view on things and
then I use the the punch lines to get it
out there but the first is is it funny
does it hit me as funny - I think it's
funny and then you know hopefully other
people will tell well well said and Bill
Santiago will be headlining at the
chuckle hut weekend you might be sharing
a it's funny good this reminds me is and
I I was in Cuban I went to a comedy
festival there and you know Kasia was
still very much in in power at the time
and I was I was so interested like what
can you get away with it yeah when the
fact there's no one knew what the line
was like sometimes they're looking
sometimes they're not sometimes some
will get carted away so you never know
they're always pushing the limit you
know and everyone on stage at night at
any moment no matter what they were
talking about could have been arrested
for for an indefinite amount of time
yeah they're just wrong about the
charges I definitely like the idea of
having the comedy police taking away the
hack it would kill the clubs again I
think that's what we need actually for
the yeah well know for the comedy scene
in this country yeah
for every once a while somebody must be
dragged lost babe I mean it would fill
the clubs you know right now we are
hurting for audiences and you have to
sort of know what should actually be
police Jenny like when Lenny Bruce when
no one he was gonna be arrested he would
somehow do and he was doing the best of
course then died of a heroin overdose
but you know we've all got problems
bonobos comm is the official outfitter
of the Reuben report use code TR r20 to
get this shirt and these jeans